99 عمليه اطلاق نار جماعي في الولايات
المتحده منذ بدايه عامنا هذا قتل خلالها
62 شخصا وجرح
159 كان اخرها في ال 23 من الشهر عندما
قتل سبعه اشخاص ونقل الى المستشفى مصاب
واحد بعد ان فتح مسلح للنار على موقعين
منفصلين في هاف مونباي اما اذا عدنا قليلا
الى العام الماضي فقد احصى ارشيف عن في
السلاح
647 عمليه اطلاق نار جماعي سقط خمسه قتلى
او اكثر في احدى 20 حاله منها كما سجلت
المجموعه 690 حادثه اطلاق نار جماعي في
عام 2021 راح ضحيتها اكثر من 28
تقول الاحصائيات الامريكيه ان مبيعات
الاسلحه في الولايات المتحده وصلت الى
الضعف منذ عام 2000 وتضيف ان هناك حوالي
393 مليون سلاح ناري مملوك للقطاع الخاص
بعباره اخرى
120 قطعه سلاح لكل 100 امريكي ارتفاع
اعداد حيازه المدنيين للسلاح واستمرار
سلسله حوادث اطلاق النار الداميه التي
شهدتها البلاد دفع الرئيس الامريكي وبيد
الى التوقيع في الخامس والعشرين من يونيو
حزيران العام الماضي على مشروع قانون جديد
ينص على التحقيق من السجيلين الجنائي
والنفسي لكل من يريد شراء سلاح بين
الثامنه عشره و 21 عاما واقر بعيد بان هذه
الاصلاحات لم يرقى الى ما كان يتطلع اليه
لكنه اصر على انها كفيله بحمايه حياه
الكثيرين فهل كانت تلك الاصلاحات كافيه
حقا لحمايه الارواح جدل يثار من جديد بين
الامريكيين الذين يتساءلون الان عن مدى
الحاجه الى اصلاحات اكثر صرامه بشان
تدابير الامان الخاصه بحيازه او حمل
السلاح